so I've seen a lot of questions online
about how gear and cosmetics work in
Hogwarts Legacy as well as the very
limited number of gear slots also when
and how do you finally get a broom well
let's start with the gear because it's
very important to understand there's a
difference between the appearance of
your gear and the actual item you'll
start the game with only 20 total gear
slots and that's all of your items
combined so while it first may appear
that it's 24. each of them it's actually
for everything now with that being said
you'll want to always make sure you are
equipping your highest level gear
regardless of what you look like even if
you don't like its appearance because
you can change it now if you're familiar
with games then you've seen things like
this before but if you're new to RPGs
then this is what's known as a transmog
system it's really a player friendly
system because it means you can have
whatever stats you want in addition to
the look you want so when you're in the
gear menu and you press X if you're on
PlayStation or a if you're on Xbox
you'll open up a sub menu for that
specific piece of gear which you can
compare to your other items in the same
slot that's how you check out if you
have anything better you'll also want to
take note of the trait later on in the
game but you don't really need to worry
about that early on now once you have
your best gear equipped then you can
back out to the main gear menu here and
this time when you hover above a piece
of gear note the appearance button
prompt here and here is where all your
appearances for gear are stored so you
aren't limited here in the total number
like you are with the actual gear piece
itself items like the dark arts cosmetic
set the house fanatic robes all of these
twitch drops we've been getting they
will appear here as well they are not
considered a piece of gear but rather a
cosmetic what's even better about this
system is that you'll keep all of your
appearances even after selling the piece
of gear so every time you obtain a new
piece of gear it's going to instantly
unlock as an appearance as well so don't
be disappointed as you're traveling
about the world finding lower level gear
because if you like the look of that you
can actually still use it as a cosmetic
and then sell the gear piece now as you
progress further through the game you
may want to hang on to more of your gear
because of the various traits that can
be applied and if you want to keep more
gear you're going to need more gear
slots and the way you unlock more gear
slots is by doing the Merlin puzzle
which are scattered about the open world
these show up on your map and require
you to solve a brief puzzle to complete
but to even access these Merlin puzzles
you're going to need mallow Suite when
you first approach the spiral pattern
you'll be prompted to use the mallow
suite and if you're out you won't be
able to start the puzzle now you can
purchase matlosuite directly from the
magic neep which is located in hogsmeade
however once you've unlocked the room of
requirement you'll want to go back to
the magic neap and purchase the seeds as
well because then you can start growing
your own and basically generate an
endless supply of mallow Suite of course
you're eventually going to need that pot
for other things but a little sneak peek
at the later game you're going to be
able to expand that as well and grow
more at the same time and there are 95
total Merlin puzzles in the game so you
will want to make sure you have plenty
of mallow Suite if you're wanting to do
all of those even though I had been
doing many of these Merlin puzzles early
on I noticed I wasn't really unlocking
anything or adding to my gear slots and
so for this reason it's very important
guys very important that you frequently
check your challenges page from the main
menu as this is where you will unlock
additional perks and items for
completing challenges throughout the
World the game will prompt you when you
have a new one at the bottom but it's
very easy to just ignore that especially
if you're really focused on a battle or
exploring the world which is absolutely
gorgeous by the way it's so easy to get
lost in this world but it's very
important that you remember even after
you complete the challenge you have to
go into this menu and then specifically
unlock the reward for it to activate as
you're traveling through the world and
completing these challenges you'll
notice a number of them are going to be
combat related and Avalanche has created
a really engaging spell system here
that's easy to understand but difficult
to master one of the things that's
really helped me so far is knowing enemy
strengths and weaknesses most enemies in
the game are going to have a specific
spell for a specific way of attacking
them that they are weak to so this is
where you want to make sure that you
don't ignore your Field Guide because
this book is a trove of information
that's helpful in battle you get to this
by navigating to the collections page
and there's going to be a category for
enemies and here you'll be able to find
an entry for every single enemy that
you've met in the game and then if you
read this entry you're gonna see a tip
or two about how best to deal with him
in battle of course pretty obvious you
know spiders are going to be weak to
fire same for inferior but there are
some surprising ones here that may
really help you out in battle I had this
really tough one with an armored troll
then went back later and read that you
can actually use flopindo in a very
specific way which I didn't have that
unlocked yet but you can use it in a
very specific way to do even more damage
to this troll alright for our next one
here another combat tip because one of
the most important combat spells to
master is protego this is considered one
of the game's essential spells by the
devs at Avalanche so you won't find it
as a slottable spell which is really
nice it's always going to be right there
mapped triangle for PlayStation and Y
for Xbox and you'll want to really
practice the timing of this while you
can simply hold it down and it will last
for about a second and a half or so if
you time it just right after you see the
little golden indicator right here it's
gonna flash above your character's head
that indicator means the incoming attack
can not only be blocked but it can be
essentially parried so if you time it
just right with an incoming spell it
will result in a perfect parry and send
the spell flying back toward the enemies
but the benefits don't end there because
if you keep holding down even after
deflecting the attack you'll fire off a
Stupify spell to stun your enemy and
stupefy is really powerful guys because
like the ancient magic attacks and the
unforgivable spells it will actually
break through any enemy Shield
regardless of its color very very useful
for tago you gotta learn it gotta Master
it now if you're having trouble maybe
controlling the camera with combat there
are a couple of interesting settings
here that you definitely should take a
look at I've noticed Hogwarts Legacy has
some rather interesting control settings
by default so there are two that I want
to show you here two things you need to
check out and see what works best for
you we'll start with the sensitivity
options because camera acceleration is
actually turned on by default now a lot
of controller players are going to be
used to third person games with no
camera acceleration so definitely
experiment with turning that down I went
down to 0.5 at first that felt better
then I just took it all the way down to
zero turned up my camera sensitivity a
little bit and that is what I have found
works perfectly for me so then you get
none of that acceleration that ramping
up also make sure you get used to R3 for
locking onto targets and then you can
flick the right stick left and right to
switch between them go ahead and test
out whether or not you prefer having the
camera relative targeting option on or
off as well this is enabled by default
and from reading some Impressions online
it seems like people are really having a
strong preference for one or the other
so definitely test that one out too and
see what works best for you and I think
taking all of those into account
together it's really going to help you
navigating the world especially in
combat now when it comes to the HUD
overall I personally prefer a very
minimal HUD which is why I've completely
turned off the minimap you notice in all
my videos there's no minimap because I
turned it off and while I may sacrifice
a bit with utility by having the minimap
turned off I really think it helps with
the overall immersion for the game
because dude trust me you want to be
immersed in this world this beautiful
world that Avalanche has created so how
I've been navigating the world is that
I'm using the quest marker and so then
you just press up on the d-pad and if
you have a quest marked it's going to
display a golden trail that you can
follow to the destination this is really
useful for navigating without the
minimap whether you're in the castle or
traveling across the world actually even
try turning off the spells it it was
just too difficult as I started
unlocking more than four spells when you
just have four it's not too bad but when
you have more than that really difficult
to manage hell you can actually get by
I'm trying that one right now with just
turning it off because there are other
cues on screen to let you know both when
your health is low and also when you
have an ancient magic attack available
what I'd really love to see them add
here is a dynamic HUD option that's
going to Auto Hide anytime you aren't in
battle or actively using a spell I think
that'd be really really nice here to
just help people get even more immersed
in this gorgeous World they've created
and speaking of that world it is just so
beautiful you guys I've heard from
numerous players saying they want to
travel everywhere either on foot or by
broom forget the Fast Travel and I
totally get it but if you're short on
time or maybe you're just looking to
knock out some quests get those trophies
quickly the game does have a very
user-friendly travel system the flu
Flames are going to be scattered all
about the world both within Hogwarts and
all across the Scottish Highlands you
can even see these locations on your map
and your minimap if you have it turned
on before unlocking them to actually
unlock them all you have to do is walk
up and you'll see the green Flames light
the icon will also change on your map
from Gray to Green letting you know that
this is now an active flu flame and then
maybe a little bit surprisingly you
actually don't need to be at a flu flame
to initiate the Fast Travel mechanic
that's right you could be anywhere all
you have to do is open up your map find
the flame location you'd like to travel
to and then press the correct button
which is going to be square on
Playstation x for Xbox and at first it
may not seem like you can travel from
outside Hogwarts back to the inside but
you actually can you can see the menus
on the left here which indicate
different locations within Hogwarts so
you can go click on one of those which
is going to open up this extra menu that
you seek I mean Hogwarts is just so big
you guys it's so big you have to open up
an extra menu to be able to see the flu
Flames here it's going to kind of zoom
in for you so you can use that menu on
the left or you can go directly over to
the little Flags here which again when
you tap on those that's going to open up
that extra section of the Hogwarts map
so you can see the flue flames in that
specific area also two of the rooms that
you're going to be traveling back and
forth to a lot are the map room which if
you haven't unlocked that yet don't
worry you'll see it and do time as well
as the rumor requirement and when you
unlock these they're going to have their
own specific section here so you could
just immediately hop to either one of
those there are also certain missions
and items you can only access based on
the time of day and while the game
doesn't really go out of its way to show
you this feature you actually can
manually choose to alter the time of day
by waiting and skipping time now there
are sometimes based on whether and the
exact timing in the game where it can be
difficult to tell whether the game is
set as night or day so another nice
quality of life option I'd love to see
is if they actually stated somewhere
when you go to change it what are you
currently on are you going tonight are
you going today all you have to do to
find this is you open up your map and
then you're going to see The Prompt here
in the bottom right it just says wait
very very helpful if you want to pass
the time and there's also going to be a
very specific Quest you guys will know
it when you come to it where to even
access this certain item it has to be
night for you to grab them so when you
find these about the world now you know
how to change it to night very easily
now I just want to quickly say if you
guys are finding this video helpful
consider subscribing to the channel for
more Hogwarts Legacy content trust me we
have so much already and we have plenty
more on the away but now let's get to
number 10 because one of the biggest
questions I keep seeing online is when
do I get a broom I want to fly retro
when can I fly let's be honest here as
great as walking is it does get old
after a while and broom flight really
opens things up in a whole new way so if
you want to get the room as fast as
possible then you're gonna have to stick
to the main missions and knock them out
as quickly as you can but I have to
stress here this is quite a few hours
into the game it's still I mean early
kind of in the grand scheme of things
but it's much later than I expected I
thought it was going to be within the
first hour to the game you were gonna
get a broom so keep doing the story
missions and eventually you're going to
get the mission for your first flying
class with Madame kogawa and after
completing this you'll then be able to
travel to hogsmead and purchase a broom
for 600 gold from spin which is sporting
needs which is one on the south side of
hogsmead blue flame travel Point very
close by now these broom controls they
do take a little bit to get used to
there's also an extra set of control
options for the broom if you look here
in the bottom right of your screen
whenever you're flying press right on
the d-pad and you're gonna see this
extra set of controls and I found one
here that made flying especially over
long distances much easier so there are
really two sorts of speed boosts for
your broom one is just a basic boost you
activate with the right trigger holding
it down whereas the left trigger will
make you go even faster however that one
is tied to the yellow meter in the
bottom right corner of your screen so
that one you'll have to kind of pace
yourself how often you're using that
boost with the left trigger the Boost
with the right trigger though is really
something that you're going to want to
hold down almost at all times unless
you're slowing down and you want to look
around see where you're at something
like that I found again if you're really
traveling a long way it can get a little
bit tiresome to keep holding down that
right trigger constantly fortunately
there's actually another way to activate
that boost and to basically just toggle
it on and it is by pressing L3 with the
left stick so the benefit here is you
press it once let go and you're gonna
maintain that speed and then of course
you can still use the L2 for that extra
boost as well but unlike the right
trigger you don't have to continuously
hold it down once you click an L3
hopefully you found these tips helpful
and hopefully you're enjoying Hogwarts
Legacy I certainly am if you're curious
to my thoughts on the game so far you
can check out the video on the right
side here your screen now which is my
Impressions after my first 20 hours with
the game as always guys thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon